power player of the week a leading voice
for conservative Millennials in a free
country it is up to you to succeed or
fail on your own merits so get off your
ass and do it yes ben shapiro talks fast
but then for most of his 33 years he's
been a man in a hurry i'm ben shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show he's the
host of the most listened to
conservative podcast in the country I do
like that Trump does have a rotating
series of about ten insults and he just
keeps going around and around he's the
editor of The Daily wire which gets 100
million page views a month and he's a
big presence on college campuses for his
militant conservative views for protest
you're not a man if you think you're a
man this exchange with a 22 year old
college student over transgender
identity has attracted 47 million views
on Facebook why can't you identify a 60
why would what what is the problem with
you identifying a 60 you're right age is
significantly less important than gender
you can't magically change your gender
you can't magically change your sex
you can't magically change your age at
the University of Utah he listed what he
calls the hierarchy of victimhood in
America so goes LGBTQ and then black
folks and then Hispanic folks and then
women and then Jews and then Asians and
then way down at the bottom white
straight males right those are the
people who are at the very bottom and
then their their opinions do not matter
at all
Shapiro has been called the voice of
conservative Millennials our
conservative Millennials different from
conservative baby boomers by the time a
lot of conservatives hit baby boomer age
there's a there's a mentality that's set
in that they're always losing and that
every choice every political choice
particularly is a lesser of two evils
choice if you're a conservative
millennial I think that you tend to be a
little bit more idealistic just as
younger people are generally while I
applaud some of President Trump policies
he says the tweets are needlessly
divisive and turn off his generation
young people in the United States
dramatically dislike this administration
and they dramatically dislike the
Republican Party and it is president
Trump's responsibility sort of
conservatives anyway to fix
and sitting there and on Twitter and
retweeting Britain first is not going to
do that
Shapiro worked for Breitbart in the
campaign but quit when he says it was
turning into a trump propaganda arm as
for Steve vana I think that Steve is
very interested in being perceived as
powerful as being perceived as a mover
and shaker I don't think he's nearly as
much of a mover and shaker as he wants
to be seen as as we've said Shapiro has
always moved fast at age five he dressed
for Halloween as John Adams by age 17 he
wrote a nationally syndicated political
column I skipped a couple of grades I
was a virtuosic violinist I actually
when I went to college thought that I
was gonna double major in genetic
science and music so I was always pretty
driven things that I hate and his only
plan now is to keep pushing his special
brand of combative conservatives
sometimes the best way to get a message
across is to just speak bluntly and so
I'm not going there to to deliberately
offend people I'm saying things that I
think are true with precisely the amount
of Verve I think necessary to convey the
message after our interview I had one
piece of advice for Sapiro
try talking a little slower so some of
us can keep up with a